[Music]
so
i've always wanted to make an app for
kona
for the amount of time that i spend with
him and the fact that he's been my dog
for six years
my number one user my number one fan
my boy who's never really ever used
technology before
i don't know i figured it would be kind
of fun to make something like that
because
i don't think he's gonna know what the
heck to do with it basically
so today we're gonna build an app for
kona but first we have to figure out
what the heck to even build him because
i mean the worlds are oyster but also
kona's abilities are a little bit
limited because he is a dog
but i think there are some real
opportunities to create
customer delight and joy and give him
something that he didn't even know he
needed
but first let's meet my dog kona kona is
six years old
and we adopted him as a puppy from a
rescue group
in san diego his breed is kind of like a
little mix of everything
we adopted it from an australian
shepherd group but it turns out
he's like six percent of every dog breed
that's out there
kona loves walks he loves treats he
loves pats
he dislikes the water and anything that
makes him uncomfortable
and before we keep going i want to say
thank you to codecademy for sponsoring
today's video so cool academy i feel
like is such a favorite within the
community so i'm really excited to work
with him as a sponsor
for those of you who don't know it's
like the easiest platform to learn how
to code
especially for beginners a lot of people
recommend this platform as a great way
to get started in coding in case you
want to also make an
app for your dog maybe i mean in terms
of starting to learn how to code
codecademy's got it all they have a
community of over 45 million learners
and they also have a weekly goal setting
tool
and 30 day challenges to help you stay
motivated in your learning you can
choose courses based on specific skills
and career paths
especially at a time where tech and
coding skills are super high in demand
within the job market
academy has a lot of courses especially
when it comes to full stack web
development
and they even have a course to help you
pass the technical interview with java
and if you want to build your own app
like i
am they've got an incredible course for
swift on ios
and kotlin on android they've also got
resources for learning and brushing up
on fundamental computer science concepts
that underlie all these technologies
they've got cheat sheets they've got
articles they've got videos and they
also have an incredible community where
you can go and ask questions
just looking through the website y'all i
think it's just a great one-stop shop
for really high quality content about
learning how to code
it is really cool that there's even a
website that consolidates all these
different technologies
into these really great interactive
courses even
this fall codecademy is showing support
for students during covert time by
launching its first ever student
membership
basically students can receive full
access to codecademy's pro plan
at a discounted price and in this effort
they've got a digital student center
and community-led chapters for college
campuses
so make sure to go to this link it's
also linked to the description box below
to see how you can unlock all of this at
codecademy
thank you so much to codecademy for
sponsoring and now let's get back to the
video
scott i'm thinking of making an app for
kona
what's that i don't know i was gonna ask
you what kind of app do you think i
should make
sleep tracker sleep tracker track how
much kona sleeps
he does sleep a lot but that would mean
that we
would use it to track his sleep wouldn't
it be cool if he interacted with the app
like he was the user
yeah that'd be cool what kind of app do
you think would be cool
a walk time app a walk time map yeah
like he would press a button at the door
and or when he wants to go outside it
would send us a notification
oh man how many times do you think you
would press that in a day
twice twice i think you only press it
twice a day i think that's a pretty
solid idea
so after consulting with my co-owner uh
co-product manager
scott yeah i think an app that would
allow kona to tell us when he wants to
go on a walk could be pretty compelling
if we're talking about it from like a
user's perspective aka
kona then it is definitely very
delightful and it helps him to
communicate in a way
that he's never been able to communicate
before so
you know number one giving the user what
they don't know they need
what they do need and then number two
customer delight
so um i'm feeling pretty good about that
so then like any good app developer
i decided to start sketching out ideas
and writing what the requirements would
be
for this app
[Music]
this is so silly excuse me sir
excuse me excuse me sir how would you
like
an app where you can tell me and scott
when you need a walk
is that something that would interest
you
how do you feel about that user
experience
what do you think
you don't really care now that i had a
basic design
i had to do like a quick user research
session with kona
to decide whether to build the dog part
of the app on an iphone
or an ipad so i tested to see what he
was more comfortable using
excuse me sir we haven't finished user
testing excuse me sir
excuse me oh scott my user ran away
well you don't pay your user
testers then but i don't think conan is
going to want an amazon gift card
[Music]
so because this app is just for one user
i kind of wanted to go above and beyond
in this
experience for kona so i recruited my
brother ray who's a ux designer
to help i'm gonna make an app for kona
and i was wondering if you'd be down to
make designs for it yeah
are you reading my help for that
yeah you want me to teach you how to
draw a circle
i need i need a designer's touch okay
yeah okay i can i can do that he sent me
the designs the next day
and without spoiling anything about how
it looks
this is my reaction to seeing the
designs he worked on
and so then i spent some time over a
couple of days to build the app
[Music]
okay so i spent more time than i thought
uh coding everything but i also did
learn a couple of new things
but the kona side of the app is
basically ready to go
so i am going to train him to try to
use it basically like this guy has no
idea how to use an ipad so i gotta do a
little bit of tree training
so let's do that and hope that all of my
efforts
have not been wasted i literally bought
some training treats for kona for this
app
and so here's me doing a method of dog
training called shaping
to try to get him to touch the ipad
kona's actually very sensitive about his
paws like he doesn't really like me even
touching them to begin with
so it definitely takes some time to get
him closer and closer to touching the
ipad
but we eventually got there yes i really
need to go outside
[Music]
i don't know i think you got it i'm
gonna try to attach this to
just the walkies thing now okay
yes good boy good boy we're going again
we're going again
[Music]
he was starting to feel more like he
could trust the ipad so here i am kind
of reinforcing his trust and the
behavior
i feel like he's actually getting kind
of tired but i don't know maybe he has
like a couple more
left in him to go walkies see if he'll
just do it on his own do you wanna go
walkies
twist a button something tells me it
hasn't quite solidified oh
yes good boy
[Music]
all right so let's see that that was a
pretty like that was a success
you can touch the button i think he sees
it too
my brother made sure that it was a very
like high contrast color that he could
see
i think he's starting to get it a little
bit i think we have to keep working on
it but we're going to take a little
break
but i am going to see if those
walkies all came onto my phone because
there's a phone aspect of this
yo
i think that worked yo
you worked kona the app here is telling
me that you really need to go outside
and then you demanded walkies now at 3
49 pm
is that right i think he's tired
what do you think we knew app i would
like to ask for your user feedback what
do you think so far
good app so far yeah you thank you so
far booby
[Music]
okay well so now that i know that it's
kind of worked i think i might make a
couple of tweaks like make the button a
little bit bigger
and only play one audio clip at a time i
wanted to show you and tell you kind of
how i built it
it's still definitely rough but
i built everything on ios using the
standard
ios sdk this is the ipad side of it it's
actually just one
app and then if it's on ipad it'll show
this if it's on iphone
it'll show this so this is just one
giant button
you tap it it changes color wookies
please and it plays
can we get wookies soon a variety
wookies
please i want to walkies which really is
just like on every tap event
i choose a random number from one
through six and then i play
that audio clip but yeah it's it's super
basic
i really need to go outside so every
time that gets tacked
it shows up as a log right here so this
is the iphone version of things
um i built this using swift ui because
i've been using swift ui for a while
and for certain things like this it is
easier to build using swift ui than the
regular ios
stuff not to bore you with the details
but there's just the header and then the
list
and the list is scrollable for the back
end i ended up using firebase for the
first time
i needed something that communicates
these devices to each other
and so i was looking for a really simple
back-end solution i found firebase
it was stupidly easy i didn't have to
really implement any sort of networking
calls i like to do is just like
add some values to something and then it
shows up so
yeah i'm really pleased with how that
turned out
it was a good chance to learn how to use
firebase so this is
pulling from the internet and there's a
lot of requests there because i was
testing things earlier
you see that you can see the time stamp
and the messages
as well as these little cute icons
of conor requesting his walks so i'd say
this was a success i'm pretty happy
about how this turned out to be honest
anyway i hope you like watching this
video i'm gonna put all this code up on
github it's gonna be open source y'all
can look at it it's not gonna be on the
app store though
just because i feel like it needs a
little bit more polish to get there
thank you so much for watching if you
like these kinds of videos where i just
like make random apps which you know
i've always actually wanted to do stuff
like this
let me know in the comments down below
let me know what other apps i should
develop that are silly and really have
no purpose
or value in the world but are just fun
things to build
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and hit the notification bell if you
want to be notified when my videos go
live
i will see you in the next one take care
everybody
bye